[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde la santé à vif
situation paradoxale alors que la
médecine française est toujours de
grandes qualités et aussi efficiente
tant au niveau des hôpitaux publics du
secteur privé alors que l'assurance
maladie permet une couverture médicale
remarquable jusqu'à une quasi gratuite
des soins alors que nos mécanismes de
solidarité sont opérationnels jusque et
y compris dans le cas d'épidémie et même
de pandémie comme on l'a vu avec la
covid 19 oui malgré tous ces satises le
système de santé ne fonctionne pas bien
et tout ou presque est à revoir dans ce
qui fut à la sortie des trentes
glorieuses c'est-à-dire entre 1945 et
1975 et jusqu'au début du 21e siècle un
modèle d'excellence plus que des trous
dans la raquette socio-médicale ce
modèle semble à bout de souffle
qu'on en juge une difficulté d'accès des
patients aux soignants à l'hôpital comme
en médecine de ville des milliers de
postes de soignants médecins infirmiers
vacances sur tout le territoire avec des
asymétries territoriales pénalisant les
populations précaires et fragiles un
paiement à l'acte inadapté et des
revendications de revenus aussi
justifiés que permanente une mauvaise
coordination des soins entre le privé et
le public une recherche médicale en
baisse une industrie biomédicale à la
traîne on l'a vu avec ce fameux vaccin
français qui n'est pas arrivé concernant
la covid bref cet inventaire n'est pas
exhaustif mais il reste à comprendre les
raisons de la dégradation de notre
système de santé dans une société qu'on
pourrait qualifier de Solid réalisation
tant les gens sont seuls ou en tout cas
on se ressentit de solitude bref notre
joyau social enviés par tant de pays
étant danger alors pour expliquer un peu
cette situation je vais le faire avec
mes invités Arnaud Robinet vous êtes à
la fois médecin président de la
Fédération hospitalière de France et
vous êtes également mère de Reims je
tiens à préciser je ne suis pas médecin
je suis docteur et sciences en
pharmacologie voilà je ne veux pas
usurper un titre merci de ce correctif
donc vous êtes mais vous vous présidez
cette fédération dont on va largement
parler alors Jacques Milliez vous êtes
gynécologue les professeur des
universités et vous êtes membre de
l'Académie nationale de médecine Patrick
Peloux vous êtes médecin hospitalier et
urgentiste et Jérôme Marty vous êtes
bien médecin et président de
l'uefml c'est quoi l'uefml en deux mots
l'Union
[Musique]
alors écoutez la situation de la santé
en France pose problème j'aimerais avoir
votre diagnostic et aussi un pronostic
sur le manque de soignants et les
solutions envisagées alors on évoque
d'un côté le vieillissement le numéro
slausus la répartition territoriale
anarchique la confusion des compétences
c'est quoi votre diagnostic Arnaud
Robinet comme ça un premier diagnostic
alors aujourd'hui tout ça c'est la
résultante de quoi d'une gestion
purement comptable depuis des dizaines
d'années depuis 20 ou 30 ans si on prend
la question du nombre de médecins
rappelez-vous il y a à peu près 15 ans
ou 20 ans avec l'accord de l'ensemble
des syndicats d'ailleurs il faut aussi
le préciser on considérait que le trou
de la Sécurité sociale était du fait
d'un trop grand nombre de médecins
presque plus il y avait le médecin plus
on allait creuser le trou de la Sécurité
sociale donc on n'a pas du tout anticipé
anticipé par rapport à quoi notamment
par rapport aux besoins de la population
dans les années à venir et notamment
avec ce vieillissement de la population
qui est une chance pour notre pays c'est
aussi le symbole de l'excellence de la
médecine et de la prise en charge mais
derrière nous n'avons pas donc anticipé
et puis tout ça bien sûr cette gestion
purement comptable a amené bien
évidemment à des difficultés d'économie
pour l'hôpital public en disant 10
milliards d'euros d'économies ont été
faits sur le dos de l'hôpital public et
donc derrière des conditions de travail
qui se sont dégradées et donc un manque
d'attractivité pour les la filière
hospitalière que ce soit d'ailleurs le
médical mais également le paramédical et
aujourd'hui nous payons les frais de
cette gestion purement comptable on va
rentrer dans le détail mais quel est
votre diagnostic à vous Jacques Millet
sur un premier diagnostic parce que
diagnostic c'est que c'est sûr que notre
système de santé est malade il est
atteint d'une poly technologies et si je
peux prendre une comparaison médicale je
dirais que c'est comme les maladies
orphelines c'est à dire qu'on a un
diagnostic mais on n'a pas de traitement
ou plutôt quand on a des traitements on
n'a pas le mode d'emploi
je crois un exemple par les urgences
pour essayer d'éteindre l'incendie des
urgences
si bien connu c'est en dernier le
ministre de la Santé François branle a
sorti le carnet de chèque bien
l'idée et la stratégie était de orienter
cet argent vers les centres privés
d'accueil des urgences sur des chargés
les services publics mais aussi de
donner des incitations financières pour
attirer vers les services d'urgence
public
des soignants nouveaux 109 selon le 109
où est-ce qu'on le prend
si on le prend dans ce qu'on pour
faciliter les choses on appellerait les
services d'aval c'est creuser un trou
pour en combler un autre et déjà service
d'aval beaucoup de difficultés les
urgences ne peuvent pas y mettre donc la
question qui se pose c'est comment faire
venir ou revenir à l'hôpital les gens
qui ne veulent pas y travailler ou qu'on
a mis dehors et là on n'a pas vraiment
de réponse mais c'est choisir ajouter
simplement un mot c'est que je crois
qu'il faut aussi avoir conscience qu'on
vit dans un monde nouveau alors c'est
pas Christophe Colomb mais c'est je
pense que c'est un monde différent et
ces gens-là c'est l'exemple
les jeunes qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail ne veulent plus travailler aux
conditions qui étaient les nôtres ils ne
veulent plus de radicaler ils ne veulent
plus les salaires minimables ils veulent
une vie privée et je forme pas les
soignants
RATP et tous les autres
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait à la RATP on va
rentrer dans tout le détail mais moi
j'aimerais avoir une première image avec
vous donc
qu'est-ce qui fait que ce modèle
d'excellence dont on parlait il y a
encore quelques années sinon quelques
décennies soit aujourd'hui
troué Patrick Peloux une première image
le public le ressent comme ça
aujourd'hui mais pour faire suite à ce
que vous venez de dire parce que en fait
c'est complémentaire je suis d'accord
avec ce qu'ils ont on pouvait être en
dissonance non pour faire suite à ça
s'il y avait un exemple à dire c'est la
prise en charge des personnes âgées
comme a dit en fait Jacques à l'instant
de polypathologies et où l'hôpital
assistance publique l'hôpital public est
devenu une prise en charge de spécialité
voire de surs spécialité de sursure
spécialité c'est à dire que la globalité
du malade on s'en est éloigné et la
formation des médecins la formation des
médecins elle est faite par des
universitaires qui ne les rapprochent
pas du monde du travail mais qui veulent
aujourd'hui je parle pas de ta
génération mais la génération des
universités aujourd'hui ils veulent que
tous les étudiants en médecine
deviennent des supers universitaires des
chercheurs de mitochondries or il y a le
quotidien le quotidien c'est de voir les
gens et tu t'aperçois qu'en fait avec le
temps
ceux qui sont valorisés dans le monde de
la santé c'est ceux qui sont le plus
éloignés des malades Patrick Paulo juste
je voudrais vous faire préciser cette
chose là vous êtes en train de dire si
j'ai bien compris que aujourd'hui les
patients sont en meilleure santé d'une
certaine manière parce que il y a toutes
les conditions de l'environnement mais
qu'on n'a pas pris en considération
cette chose là et qu'on pense régler
tout ça par de la technique de la
technique et de la technique très
important ce que vous venez de dire
c'est à dire que et ça ça rejoint ce que
disait monsieur robinet tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que
on a cru qu'en améliorant
l'environnement en améliorer la santé on
a oublié le vieillissement de la
population qui a explosé et le
vieillissement a été révélé en 2003 avec
la canicule de 2003 on s'aperçu que les
gens vieillissent et oui les gens
vieillissent et de plus en plus et en
effet il y a eu cette
façon de voir les malades comme une
continuité avec leur environnement
social on améliorait le social donc ils
allaient bien non c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça et on s'est trompé faut
juste reconnaître ça fait à peu près 20
à 30 ans qu'on s'est totalement trompé
sur la santé et je vous redis ce je sais
pas si j'aurai l'occasion mais il faut
redonner de l'importance à la ville
comme à l'hôpital on va voir médecin qui
sont au pied du lit du malade alors
Jérôme Marty vous avez écouté ce qui
vient d'être dit mais j'aimerais avoir
votre avis à vous parce que vous vous
défendez les médecins de ville si on
peut dire
tout ça est arrivé comme ça par hasard
on découvre alors que c'est un phénomène
que s'agisse du vieillissement qu'il
s'agisse du numérique clausus etc c'est
des choses qui ont été qui sont datées
donc quand vous expliquez cette rien
n'est arrivé par hasard mais d'abord je
voudrais rebondir sur une réflexion que
vous avez eu en tout début d'émission
qui est celle de parler de notre système
solidaire qui est un joyau on est quand
même le seul pays du monde où on
opérateur ouvert un SDF et ça on le dira
jamais assez et ce système qui va très
mal continue à tourner pourquoi il
tourne il tourne parce que les gens dont
parlait Patrick tout à l'heure qui sont
les mains qui soignent quel qu'il soit
qu'ils soient à l'hôpital ou en ville
continue à tenir le système à bout de
bras dans des conditions déplorables ils
sont épuisés et pourtant ça tourne mais
la question qu'on doit se poser c'est
jusqu'à quand parce que oui ce système
va mal il va même très mal et qu'on
exerce à l'hôpital ou qu'on exerce en
ville
quand on a l'expérience qu'on peut avoir
avec une vingtaine d'années ou plus de
pratique on doit dire qu'on n'a jamais
connu une situation comme celle
d'aujourd'hui jamais jamais et c'est
venu d'une certaine idée économique du
soin en 96 monsieur Juppé a créé l'Honda
l'objectif national dépasse d'assurance
maladie on a mis toutes les dépenses
dans une enveloppe contrainte et à
partir de là on a pu regarder la santé
que sous l'angle du goutte et on a
oublié ce qu'elle pouvait apporter au
pays non seulement en termes de richesse
mais en termes de socialisation en
termes de professionnalisation en termes
de
l'espérance de vie a continué à croître
malgré ce que vous dites
déterminant santé c'est 20%, il faut pas
oublier que vous avez la pollution vous
avez l'amélioration la pollution vous
avez l'amélioration d'accidentologie par
la par l’amélioration des voitures etc
c'est pas que de la santé c'est pas que
de la santé mais aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas un seul Français pas un français ou
m'entendez qu'il soit en ville à la
campagne en zone rurale qui ne le
connaissent pas des difficultés d'accès
aux soins et ça c'est la résultante des
politiques sanitaires successives
il y a des criminels qui ont poignardé
la santé et il y a des empreintes sur le
manche ou traité carrément les
politiques de criminels vous allez pas
un peu loin non je ne vais pas un peu
loin je pense que si vous voulez on n'a
pas voulu te dire compte de la richesse
de ce pays il a encore une fois la
richesse de ce pays c'est les mains qui
soignent on a totalement oublié ça on
n'a pas voulu se pencher sur ses
soignants qui tiennent à bout de bras le
système et on les a à force d'ignorance
on les a oublier
une question précise aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on a le plus besoin
puisqu'on dit qu'on a la technique et là
est-ce que c'est des généralistes est-ce
que c'est des pédiatres est-ce que c'est
des urgentistes tout est-ce que c'est
des gériatres vous avez besoin de
généraliste des spécialistes libéraux
parce que sans généraliste spécialiste
libéraux ne pour l'hôpital ne peut pas
aller mal vous avez besoin d'être
soignant d'infirmiers d'hospitalier
parce que sans eux la médecine il ne
peut pas aller mal ne peut pas aller
bien les deux systèmes sont profondément
interfacés on a besoin en fait de
soignants on a besoin de sens et on a
besoin de soignants heureux parce que
vous ne pouvez exercer la médecine que
si vous êtes heureux or aujourd'hui à
l'hôpital comment ville vous n'avez plus
de soigner heureux vous avez des
soignants inquiets et c'est ce qui
explique que la santé s'effondre aussi
donc la santé malheureuse mais alors
Monsieur robinet quand même je voudrais
pour noter les spectateurs qu'est-ce qui
manque concrètement est-ce que ce sont
des gériats presque ce sont des
pédiatres est-ce que ce sont des
gynécologues à l'hôpital qu'est-ce
qu'ils manque il manque de tout de
toutes les spécialités on peut parler de
gynéco obstétricien on peut parler de
psychiatre de pédopsychiatre on peut
parler de pédiatre de gériatres dans
toutes les spécialités il manque il y a
des postes vacants et donc aujourd'hui
je dirais la ce qui est indispensable il
y a l'urgence c'est de mener une petite
attractivité de mettre en avant le tous
ces métiers hospitaliers je prends
toujours un exemple moi je suis toujours
stupéfait des campagnes de communication
du ministère de la Défense des dizaines
de millions d'euros mettent en avant
tout tous les métiers et ben pourquoi on
ne fait pas la même chose pour la santé
faisant des grandes campagnes de
communication alors c'est pas l'alpha
Omega bien évidemment mais en mettant en
avant tous ces métiers de la santé et
derrière la tractivité ce n'est pas
uniquement la question de la
rémunération même si je vous rejoins un
professeur sur le sujet de la
rémunération à l'hôpital mais ce sont
les conditions de travail c'est aussi
avoir le bien-être au travail et
aujourd'hui moi quand je vois des
infirmières des aides-soignantes qui me
disent monsieur le Président vous savez
j'aime mon métier mais là j'en peux plus
parce que je considère que je le fais
mal parce que je n'arrive pas à
m'occuper de la personne âgée que j'ai
dans mon service Alzheimer dans l'EHPAD
et donc je suis mal je ne peux plus
faire mon métier alors que je me suis
engagé c'est une vocation un sacerdoce
aujourd'hui je me suis je me sens mal
j'aime l'hôpital j'aime mon métier mais
je considère que je ne fais pas comme je
devrais le faire et c'est ce qui dirait
me donne envie de quitter le système de
santé
pour répondre quand même à la question
pour qu'on reste pas dans des
généralités est-ce qu'il manque des
urgentistes oui France oui bien sûr
le premier accès à l'hôpital et
l'urgence nous nous l'avons vu cet été
ou pour la première fois de notre
histoire nous avons fermé à peu près à
intervalles réguliers et dans le temps
de manière différente à peu près une
centaine 150 à peu près services
d'urgence par manque de médecin par
manque d'infirmière etc ce que dit
Arnaud Robinet est intéressant c'est que
d'un coup il y a
l'armée fait des campagnes pour dire
venez travailler la santé fait des
campagnes pour dire ne venez pas
l'hôpital vous voyez différence de
communication j'ai et en effet on manque
de médecins et quand vous vous retournez
vers les universitaires qui tiennent les
années d'études ils vous disent non non
faut pas attention c'est eux un peu les
responsables les gens de l'ombre là les
universitaires les doyens parce que
personne
qu'il fallait un humérus clausus
mais Arnaud Robinet n'a parlé tout à
l'heure les médecins sont aussi
responsables à l'époque les syndicats de
médecins ont défendu le numerus clausus
c'était un peu la situation qu'on a
connu avec les pharmaciens quand les
pharmaciens ont accepté des quotas c'est
parce qu'ils étaient trop nombreux vous
aviez un rapport de 1 à 7 entre les
zones sur le thé en pharmacie et les
zones sous-totées et donc ils ont
accepté cela et les médecins pour
protéger leur activité on dit aussi à
l'époque avec les politiques on va
diminuer le nombre qui a pris la
décision de réduire le nombre de lits
dans les hôpitaux mais oui ça c'est les
années c'est les années 74 les années 74
et on a continué notamment avec cet
injonction notamment donné aux
établissements publics et de notre santé
avec vers plus d'ambulatoires mais sauf
que derrière plus d'ambulatoires c'est
une prise en charge du patient à la
sortie de l'hôpital donc par la médecine
de ville par le médecin généraliste par
des spécialistes et malheureusement
aujourd'hui le constat est que par
manque de médecins forcément cette
ambulatoire ne fonctionne pas comme il
devrait fonctionner et puis la fermeture
de lit aujourd'hui elle est aussi
corrélée au manque de dans nos hôpitaux
quand vous quand l'hôpital public
accueille 85% des patients covid durant
ces deux dernières années derrière ça
amène à l'activation des fameux plans
blancs et donc on transfère des
infirmières d'être soignantes dans
d'autres dans le service covid derrière
parce qu'il y a plus personne autour du
malade alors et quand même une question
qui fâche
trois d'entre vous ici son médecin vous
vous avez une responsabilité
hospitalière la formation d'un médecin
aujourd'hui c'est 6 7 ans avec une
spécialité ça fait avec une spécialité
ça fait largement 10 ans
selon ce que vous souhaitez en formation
jusqu'à la retraite pourquoi pas mais
alors la question c'est que si on veut
remédier à ça ça va prendre quelques
années or est-ce que les médecins ne se
sont pas opposés pardonnez-moi à une
complémentarité qui viendrait
infirmiers des infirmières de l'ensemble
des paramédicaux pour avoir un
encadrement sanitaire infiniment plus
étoffé non mais il y a plein d'idées
dans ce que vous dites l'idée si vous
voulez comprendre ce qui s'est passé
dans les années 70 par exemple c'est
comprendre la construction des
autoroutes très important on construit
l'autoroute A6 et en même temps qu'on
construit l'autoroute A6 on construit un
hôpital tous les 50 km en se disant il y
a l'accidentologie il faut mettre les
gens à l'hôpital etc on en est plus là
ça évolué il y a eu en effet des progrès
de faits sur la sécurité routière etc
etc tout ça donc on a fermé et regroupé
ces hôpitaux mais du coup l'économie est
allée trop loin et l'économie en effet
comme dit Monsieur robinet fort
justement on est allé trop loin dans
l'économie de santé et maintenant on est
en dessous de la moyenne européenne pour
le nombre de lits médicaux chirurgicaux
et obstétrique
dans la profession et le moment où il
s'installe il y a 20 ans qui se passe ça
veut dire aussi que aujourd'hui là ce
jour vous avez potentiellement 40 à 50
000 médecins qui attendent de
s'installer qui sont la disponibles qui
bénéficie de la meilleure formation du
monde parce que l'école de médecine
française est une des meilleures du
monde et on ne fait rien pour qu'il
s'installe pourquoi il s'installe pas
parce qu'on a rendu leur métier
tellement peu attractif qu'aujourd'hui
il réfléchissent 10 ans 25 années parce
qu'ils ont peur que l'exercice ne soit
pas pérenne donc médecin eux-mêmes qui
rendent la tractivité de leur profession
c'est pas l'état qui va les rendre ça
serait si parce que l'État à la main sur
tout l'État aujourd'hui à la main sur
l'organisation du soin l'état défini le
poids administratif dans notre exercice
il définit les temps de nos soins que
vous avez il ne nettoie pas votre
profession et vous vous retrouvez avec
des actes qui aujourd'hui n'ont plus
lieu d'être et qui vous prennent du
temps et aujourd'hui quand vous rentrez
chez vous le soir après avoir très 20 30
40 patients vous savez que vous avez
laissé 10 patients 15 patients au bord
de la route et ça vous ne pouvez pas
l'AC peut-être que chaque milliès va
répondre sur la question de la vérité
avec les infirmiers les infirmières et
tout le personnel paramédical exactement
le sujet pour
faire revenir ou faire venir les
infirmiers infirmières à l'hôpital et
leur donner plus de compétences on leur
propose un temps Émile on leur propose
de revaloriser la fonction en leur
déléguant des tâches et en même en
permettant un accès direct des patients
vers les infirmiers vers quoi certains
médecins à quoi s'opposent parce qu'il
pense que ça fait les courts-circuités
bon moi je suis gynécologue et j'ai
assisté à l'émancipation de la
profession de sage-femme
sage-femmes c'est différent parce
qu'elles font partie de la profession
médicale néanmoins sur le temps j'ai vu
elles sont compétences médicales
réglementées et j'ai vu leur
complémentarité énormément
les écoles des achats mettaient dirigées
par des gynécologues j'en étais
maintenant sans les sages-femmes qui
dirige les sages-femmes ont le droit de
faire les échographies tricales elles
ont le droit de prescrire de s'occuper
de la santé des femmes même dans
l'enceinte elle a une prescrit de la
contraception elle ne participe à aux
IVG
médicamentseuses et elles ont une
filière qui maintenant l'igace vient me
proposer de augmenter encore la
compétence de sages-femmes par une
sixième année d'étude qui est un
troisième cycle court qui va déboucher
sur un doctorat en sciences de la
maïeutique est-ce que ça a été fait au
détriment de la cavité des gynécologues
non est-ce que ça a été fait est-ce
qu'on peut transposer ça à la profession
des infirmiers à mon avis non pourquoi
parce qu'il y a jamais autant de pénurie
de sage-femme dans les hôpitaux jamais
les sages-femmes ne veulent plus
travailler dans les salles
d'accouchement elle ne veut plus le
collège de gynécologue vient de lancer
un SOS salle de naissance c'est la
panique donc
l'éventail c'est tellement ouvert que
les jeunes sages-femmes ne veulent plus
travailler là on a besoin de travail
donc c'est peut-être nécessaire mais
c'est sûrement pas suffisant merci
[Musique]
alors on va rentrer si vous voulez dans
le détail à la fois au niveau de
l'hôpital et au niveau de la médecine
libérale
bon
vous avez dit avec éloquence que le
système de santé aujourd'hui ne
fonctionne pas
s'il y avait quelque chose à faire en
urgence à l'hôpital monsieur robinet
qu'est-ce que vous souffleriez à
Monsieur Macron puisque nous sommes en
France à un système vertical ou les
impulsions viennent d'en haut c'est une
question très difficile que vous me
posez pour la première raison c'est
qu'il y a pas une urgence il y a des
urgences c'est urgences vous savez le
système de santé français il ne sera il
ne va pas évoluer si on s'ada uniquement
à l'hôpital beaucoup de réformes ont été
qualifiés d'hospitalo centriste ou
centrisme on a vu que ça fonctionnait
pas et je reviens sur ce que disait je
remarque tout à l'heure l'hôpital il va
fonctionner si la médecine ville va
fonctionner et vice versa donc il faut
renforcer cette coopération cette
complémentarité avec la médecine de
ville bien sûr et aussi avec le privé
aujourd'hui ou de grandes difficultés
avec certains établissements privés
notamment en termes d'urgence quand on
ferme les urgences dans un clinique
privée derrière ou il n'y a pas je
dirais de plan blanc activer dans le
privé forcément c'est l'hôpital qui qui
en subit les conséquences est-ce que
vous diriez monsieur robinet une petite
précision la loi Bachelot 2010 était
scandaleuse en écartant les médecins de
la gestion des hôpitaux sans langue de
bois sans langue de bois je vais vous
dire j'étais jeune depuis à l'époque je
n'ai pas voté la loi HPST c'était le
premier texte de loi que je devais voter
en arrivant en tant que je ne député
c'est le processus de loi que je n'ai
pas voté parce que je considérais que ça
ne répondait pas forcément en tout cas
au besoin de l'hôpital notamment à son
fonctionnement aujourd'hui il faut
corriger ça aujourd'hui alors je vais
vous dire aujourd'hui quand je vois que
le prénom de la République agite d'un
chiffon rouge mais comme priorité la
question la gouvernance de l'hôpital
pour moi c'est pas l'urgence aujourd'hui
il y a d'autres urgences il y a d'autres
il y a d'autres dossiers à prendre en
main aujourd'hui depuis 2021 cette
gouvernance bissiéphale elle existe
entre la direction générale et le
président la présidente de la CM1 et
puis une finie dans un établissement
comme en toute structure il y a
quelqu'un qui prend les décisions il y a
quelqu'un qui endosse les
responsabilités pénales il y a quelqu'un
qui doit décider mais aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs la Conférence des Présidents
de CME afin communiquer il y a 24 heures
en disant qu'il n'est pas l'urgence
aujourd'hui dans ce que l'on attend pour
faire évoluer le système de santé donc
cela fonctionne dans 95% des
établissements publics de santé il y a
la loi 2021 2021 on peut bien évidemment
les évaluer voir comment ça fonctionne
mais ce n'est pas l'urgence aujourd'hui
par contre qui serait intéressant c'est
de redonner peut-être un peu plus de
place
osez les locaux au sein de l'hôpital et
notamment arrêter ce conseil de
surveillance et revenir un conseil
d'administration et avec comme patron
également le maire le le président du
conseil d'administration qui a géré des
aussi les objectifs qui connaissent son
territoire qui peut participer justement
développement du système de santé sur
son territoire en connaissant les
besoins les attentes des citoyens et qui
peut également permettre de mettre
autour de la table sur un territoire
l'ensemble des acteurs du monde de la
santé les associations d'usagers la
médecine de ville l'ensemble des
collectivités les établissements publics
comme d'habissements privés c'est ce
qu'on appelle pour tout vous dire à la
FHF la responsabilité populationnelle et
en se donnant des objectifs en termes de
prévention en termes d'accès aux soins
une petite précision puisque vous
occupez de la Fédération Hospitalière on
dit que les gros budgets passent vers le
technique là où il y a le plus
d'applications scientifiques est-ce
qu'il faudrait pas mieux dispatcher ça
et ne pas consacrer de l'essentiel du
budget à la technicité médicale mais
plutôt que ça aille vers les urgences
vers discipline qui n'exigent pas de
technicité non mais on peut pas opposer
l'un à l'autre bien évidemment qu'on a
besoin d'hommes de femmes qui pratiquent
la médecine aux j'irai au pied du lit du
patient etc c'est nécessaire et la
médecine c'est le contact humain c'est
la relation humaine et ça rien ne
l'enlèvera mais on ne peut pas non plus
mettre de côté l'évolution la technique
la recherche l'innovation
vers d'autres disciplines qui sont moins
pourvu non je pense que c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas le sujet excusez-moi je
pense que c'est pas le sujet c'est pas
ce qui améliorera le fonctionnement de
l'hôpital et la prise en charge du
patient je pense que les deux sont
véritablement nécessaires par contre et
je pensais que vous allez me poser la
question pour l'hôpital public
concernant je veux dire l'administration
parce que il y a un peu un fantasme
aussi qui circule en disant que dans les
hôpitaux il y a trop d'administratifs
par rapport aux patients l'administratif
dans un hôpital c'est 10%. et on ne et
on inclut dans ces discours mais il peut
y avoir 10% et beaucoup de bureau aussi
mais on inclut dans ces 10% également
les secrétaires médicaux je rappelle que
dans les autres fonctions publiques
territoriales ou fonction d'Etat voilà
c'est entre 15 et 16%. donc voilà il
faut aussi remettre les choses à leur
place aujourd'hui l'hôpital public il a
besoin d'une chose il a besoin d'hommes
et de femmes il a besoin d'une
réorganisation je dirais en son sens il
a besoin de visibilité et notamment
c'est pour ça quand on parle d'hondables
nous on demande des plans pluriannuels
pour qu'on ait une visibilité sur le
moyen et le long terme qu'on accentue la
prévention et qu'en fin on arrive dans
ce pays à coordonner la médecine de
ville et l'hôpital public c'est une
nécessité indispensable toujours sur
l'hôpital Patrick Pelloux vous vous êtes
urgentiste on dit que
à l'hôpital c'est le généraliste du
pauvre c'est à dire que quand on peut
pas aller se faire soigner ailleurs on
va voir un urgentiste et donc en
bouteillage et quelquefois les soins
suffisants etc vous adhérez à ça je suis
pas une insulte
généraliste pas une insulte pauvre n'est
pas une insulte je suis là pour les gens
qui sont pauvres et les gens qui sont
pauvres c'est souvent ceux qui sont avec
la maladie vous savez nous serons tous
dépendants et la question n'était pas
morale de ma part c'était elle était en
termes de d'impossibilité de la moralité
dans l'ombre de votre question
maintenant dans la lumière
moral mais il y avait une question
d'accès aux soins l'accès aux soins
écoutez les urgences il faut que ça
reste
ouvert à tout le monde quand vous voulez
c'est la garantie de la sécurité pour la
population c'est le phare dans la nuit
de la société qui est en fait une
société qui abandonne l'autre vous avez
vu comment on abandonne l'autre on vous
fait croire vous n'êtes pas seul parce
que vous avez 100000 followers sur votre
compte machin en fait vous avez jamais
été aussi seul et et donc nous sommes
cette lumière et il faut la garantir en
effet vous avez un certain nombre
d'urgences qui sont en train de dire
mais finalement nous sommes un peu une
élite nous ne verrons que les urgences
75% des gens qui viennent aux urgences
non rien à y faire nous devons les
éconduire ce qui conduit d'ailleurs à
des erreurs médicales soient dites en
passant ce qui fait que non il faut
garantir ça simplement c'est le sens de
tout ça et pour faire suite à ce que
disait monsieur robinet fort justement à
partir du moment où vous avez un nom
d'âme qui est à 3,5 quelque chose comme
ça 3 5 3 6 et que vous avez une
inflation qui est à 8 9 10
on est déficitaire donc on a perdu de
bailler les règles du jeu dès le début
son pipés vous ajoutez à ça que c'est
très bien de parler des boulangers
j'adore mon boulanger etc son prix de
l'énergie son coup de l'énergie
formidable le gouvernement va faire des
mesures pour eux mais personne ne parle
du coup majeur de l'énergie pour les
hôpitaux de du budget pharaonique qu'il
faut pour chauffer un hôpital pour
mettre l'électricité partout et voyez
tout ça tout ça ça fait que d'un coup on
est écrasé et au bout du bout les
infirmières on ferme des lits donc du
coup vous avez embouteillage aux
urgences et ce qui fait que plus vous
fermez de lit regardez nous sommes
passés en disant de 12 millions de
fréquentations des urgences on a dépassé
les 24 millions là parce que derrière ça
la permanence de soins c'est-à-dire le
travail de nuit le week-end des jours
fériés etc a été délaissé mais c'est pas
regarde écoutez bien c'est très
important ce n'est pas la faute du
gouvernement parce que quand il y a eu
le Ségur dirigé par Jean Castex qui
était l'ancien directeur des hôpitaux
ils ont dit il faut valoriser la
permanence de soins que ce soit à la
ville comme à l'hôpital qui n'a pas
voulu qui n'a pas voulu trois syndicats
sur 4 3 syndicats de praticien
hospitalité autour de la table qui ont
dit on veut pas valoriser la nuit et les
jours fériés bilan des courses voilà
même pas fallu attendre des années on
est dans une déconfiture totale sur la
permanence des soins à tel point que
pour la première fois au moment des
fêtes on a été obligé d'organiser au
SAMU de Paris un véhicule léger pour
aller faire les certificats de décès
parce que plus personne voulait faire
les certificats de décès à Paris tout à
l'heure vous avez écouté alors je vais
passer à la médecine libérale mais avant
de passer à médecine libérale une
précision Jacques Méliès vous êtes à
l'Académie nationale de médecine est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment que dans les
réformes qui sont envisagées dans le
domaine de la santé pas uniquement avec
ce gouvernement mais disons depuis
quelques décennies les décisions qui
sont prises par les politiques sont
instruites en j'allais dire en
collaboration en tout cas en tenant
compte de vos avis
pas du tout non non heureusement parce
que je désire pour totalement les
décisions qui sont prises par les
politiques et j'entends pas beaucoup
d'ailleurs les académies proposées des
choses constructives et là pourtant la
plupart des ministres de la santé sont
des médecins bon alors oui mais alors le
président de l'Académie est Mattei
l'ancien ministre catastrophique de 2002
donc comment tu veux faire tenir
un plan santé moi je le conçois comme un
puzzle un puzzle où chacun va apporter
sa pièce à condition qu'elle s'articule
de façon harmonieuse avec les autres
mais un puzzle qui prend la santé le
système de son âme mais aussi tout ce
qui n'est pas le système de son qui doit
s'articuler avec un exemple
l'aménagement du territoire comment
est-ce qu'on peut espérer conserver un
hôpital de proximité qui est pourtant le
premier employeur de la ville dans bien
des cas alors qu'il
gendarmerie il y a plus de cinéma les
gens s'en vont comment peut-on
contraindre ou inciter des gens des
soignants à venir s'y installer alors
certains débutaient le propose de
obliger les médecins à venir s'y
installer mais c'est totalement
illusoire alors que déjà les médecins ne
s'installe pas alors qu'ils sont libres
dans le faire oui ils le veulent comment
irait-il s'installer ils ne veulent pas
donc il y a pas de solution pour
l'instant c'est le noir absolu moi je ne
vois pas solution un autre exemple qui
me permettait la féminisation de la
profession médicale très bien il y a pas
besoin d'avoir lu la nuit Arnaud pour
comprendre que les femmes ont des vies
multiples elles ont une vie
professionnelle et puis elles ont la
plupart d'entre elles une vie de famille
qui les oblige et qui nous oblige il
nous oblige à tenir compte de
l'amplitude d'ouverture des cabinets
et la participation service de garde bon
le Parlement est en train de voter une
loi qui va obliger tous les soignants en
libéraux à participer au garde parce que
les femmes mères des familles vont le
faire ça va être comme pour l'obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants il y a un
certain nombre qui vont se conformer
puis l'autre qui vont dire non on s'en
va et dans la suite si on veut pas être
soignant on se fait pas avec si on peut
pas être vaccinant c'est pas soignant si
on veut pas participer au service de
garde de
nuits tout ce que moi le professeur midi
à cette importance et ça reflète de
choses c'est la méconnaissance totale de
ces professions la méconnaissance
jusqu'à l'oubli et l'incapacité
prévisionnelle c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on avait des politiques
qui faisaient des plans quinquennaux qui
avaient une longue vue et aujourd'hui on
a des politiques qui résonnent à l'année
quand c'est pas au moins l'urgence
et ça c'est dramatique et bien sûr ça
c'est dramatique parce que si vous si
vous ajoutez la méconnaissance à
l'incapacité prévisionnelle vous arrivez
à ce qu'on connaît là
dans ce domaine il y a deux secteurs il
y a le secteur conventionné du secteur 1
pardonnez-moi et le secteur dit 2 ou les
honoraires sont libres on a vu ces
derniers temps la revendication de tous
les syndicats généralistes c'était de
porter la consultation de 25 à 50 euros
ça ne s'est pas fait mais à votre avis
vous croyez que c'est faisable au regard
des finances de l'état où trouver les 8
ou 9 milliards nécessaires à cette
chose-là et est-ce que c'est le seul
problème qui règlerait si je puis dire
la situation des généralistes première
chose c'est pas huit à 9 milliards monté
à 50 euros si l'on intègre dans ce tarif
tous les forfaits toutes les entrées
diverses et variées qu'on peut avoir
autour du tarif de 25 euros c'est en
gros entre un milliard et 3 milliards
mais
si vous rendez attractif ce métier si
vous avez plus de médecins qui
s'installe si ces médecins là s'occupent
mieux de la dictologie par exemple et
des ALD pour 1 euro les affections
longue durée pour 1 euro dépensé c'est 5
euros de bénéfices pour le pays
ça veut dire qu'encore une fois que la
santé n'est pas un coûte c'est un
investissement mais encore faut-il
investir dans les mains qui soignent ce
qu'on ne veut pas faire depuis des
années et ça c'est gravissime alors ce
50 euros il peut choquer mais quand vous
prenez les différentes revendications
des syndicats que vous ayez trois
niveaux de consultation ou que vous ayez
une augmentation de l'acte de base en
gros la moyenne vous retrouvez la
moyenne européenne qui est à 50 que vous
passiez par des forfaits ou par du
paiement à l'acte vous êtes obligé d'en
arriver là parce qu'aujourd'hui il y
avait 25 euros vous créez le désert
médical parce que si vous voulez vous
implantez dans Paris par exemple au prix
où sont les loyers vous pouvez pas faire
tourner votre cabinet c'est impossible
si vous voulez aller à la campagne avec
une désindustrialisation avec du chômage
avec tout ce que vous voulez sans moyen
du tout de service public qui ont
désertés qui sont partis avec 25 euros
vous en sortez pas dans une balle
difficile à 25 euros vous en sortez pas
si vous n'avez pas dans la tête à côté
de ça que la santé est devenue le
deuxième métier du ménage
ça aussi c'est primordial c'est-à-dire
qu'avant dans un couple la santé était
le premier métier aujourd'hui c'est
devenu le deuxième métier du ménage ce
qui veut dire que le conjoint ou la
conjointe un métier encore plus
technique
et donc en ruralité vous ne pouvez pas
trouver un métier au conjoint ou la
conjointe et ça c'est une difficulté
monsieur Marty j'ai entendu les pouvoirs
publics dire que ce que gagner les
médecins généralistes y compris en
secteur 1
n'était pas défavorisé par rapport à ce
que ce qu'il pouvait gagner dans
d'autres pays d'Europe c'est vrai ou
c'est pas vrai mais non mais oui il faut
aussi comparer ce que il faut il faut
aussi raisonner arrêter de raisonner à
l'instant T mais raisonner sur une vie
il faut aussi raisonner au nombre
d'heures il faut raisonner à
l'épuisement il faut raisonner au rôle
et la responsabilité dans un calcul tout
ces facteurs entre un jeu si vous restez
juste sur ce qu'il y a en bas à droite
de la feuille c'est pas un raisonnement
on en reste là sur l'économie alors
justement tu ne veux pas je voudrais
vous poser une question précise le
paiement à l'acte pour téléspectateur
c'est à dire quand un patient va chez un
médecin il y a une consultation c'est un
acte et donc on doit payer aujourd'hui
en secteur 1 c'est à dire conventionné
remboursé par la Sécurité sociale c'est
25 euros si c'est un secteur 2 c'est ça
peut être deux fois trois fois etc
ce paiement à l'acte est-ce que ça
pousse pas à l'inflation des actes pour
se retrouver financièrement et est-ce
que vous seriez favorable à ce que ça
évolue par exemple dans certains pays
scandinaves on a un forfait annuel par
patience c'est-à-dire que c'est pas
le nombre d'actes mais il y a une somme
qui est consacrée pour soigner le
patient et j'aimerais avoir votre avis à
tous là-dessus ce qui permettrait de ne
pas voir si vous voulez cette inflation
et permettrait à la fois et au patients
et aux médecins du nombre d'actes c'est
le manque de médecins c'est surtout ça
moi quand j'embauche le matin à 7h du
matin j'ai ouvert une consultation de 7H
à 8H pour permettre aux gens qui n'ont
pas de médecins qui sont sur Montauban
et qui vont bosser sur Toulouse de
trouver un médecin parce qu'il n'en
trouve pas
je sais que le soir quand j'arrête j'en
ai laissé plusieurs bords de la route
comme je vous disais précédemment c'est
ça qui fait monter surtout le le
reste sur le le le secteur 2 comme vous
dites on aurait libre dans quantité de
spécialité sans honoraire libre c'est
spécialités disparaissent parce que les
actes n'ont pas été revalorisés depuis
20 à 30 ans voire plus et sur le fait de
changer le système de prendre un peu ce
que font les scandales ils ont mis en
place ce qu'on appelle le paiement à
l'épisode de soins ou le paiement au
parcours de soins et ça c'est magique
parce que ceux qui l'ont mis en place et
qui le veulent vous disent oh là mais
c'est merveilleux les complications
chirurgicales ont disparu évidemment
dans l'enveloppe que l'on donne les
complications chirurgicales ne sont pas
prises en compte elles ne sont pas dans
l'enveloppe et donc font les directions
hospitalières elles disent au médecin
choisi moi des malades qui font pas de
complications et comme par magie on fait
disparaître des complications est-ce que
c'est vraiment ce système qu'on veut en
France je pense pas monsieur robinet sur
le paiement à l'acte nous serions
favorable à ce qu'on évolue et quand
c'était l'annonce durant la République
lors son discours aux vœux au personnel
de santé vous savez aujourd'hui le
paiement à l'acte représente à peu près
50% des recettes de l'hôpital nous
disons nous y sommes favorables à sa
suppression à la suppression de la tout
est de ça bien évidemment mais il faut
que ça concerne bien évidemment l'hôtel
public comme le secteur privé je pense
aux établissements privés et notamment
les cliniques et à la fachf nous sommes
pas opposés à avoir des financements qui
sont orientés en fonction des objectifs
de santé publique en termes de également
de deux missions et donc c'est aussi une
chose qui avait demandé une certaine
manière la FHF revoir ce T2A ou tout T2A
dans le financement de l'hôpital public
qui ne représente que 50% du financement
[Musique]
alors on va essayer
d'ouvrir quand même une perspective on
va pas rester que dans ce pessimisme là
vous êtes en tant que médecin ou même
tant que responsable de
l'Hospitalier des hôpitaux vous êtes là
pour soigner c'est-à-dire donner de
l'espoir aux gens et garantir un accès
aux soins garantir l'accès aux soins ce
qui rend les gens plus optimistes et
plus heureux alors la question que je
vous pose c'est que on a vu qu'il y
avait beaucoup de trous dans la raquette
comme on dit et que ça va pas bien la
foi pour la médecine libérale la
médecine hospitalière les
urgences etc les jeunes générations qui
ont du mal à s'installer etc
on est la santé bien sûr c'est un droit
mais ça c'est pour le citoyen mais au
niveau des pouvoirs publics c'est un
système de rationnement quand même à
travers la sécurité sociale etc et les
professionnels de santé vous avez à vous
accommoder de cette chose là au-delà des
investissements des dépenses à faire
est-ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui que
la situation justifierait
une nouvelle loi cadre quelque chose qui
serait plus qu'une grande réforme mais
des états généraux de la santé pour
remettre tout le monde à la table c'est
à dire les généralises les Hospitaliers
les urgences les mandarins pardonnez-moi
Jacques médié c'est comme ça qu'on
appelle les grands patrons en médecine
sans connotation asiatique est-ce que ça
vous paraît une bonne chose Patrick
Peloux ça a déjà été fait des dizaines
de fois oui mais alors une utilité au
regard de la gravité dire qu'en fait
regarde la gravité moi je crois la
démocratie je crois
à l'importance des parlements c'est à
dire qu'en fait il faudrait probablement
inventer quelque chose de nouveau qui ne
soit pas cette espèce de de guignolerie
du tirage au sort de citoyens je sais
pas quoi ça c'est n'importe quoi
totalement d'accord il faut remettre les
mers président du conseil
d'administration des hôpit parce que là
vous avez et finalement les mères c'est
les meilleurs représentants en fait des
besoins de la population premièrement
deuxièmement en effet définir une loi
cadre qui soit aux deux tiers des non
pas deux assemblées mais des trois
assemblées ce qu'on oublie toujours le
Conseil économique social et
environnemental qui fait des rapports
fabuleux fabuleux ou ils écoutent tout
le monde où vous avez dans ce Parlement
les représentants syndicaux etc y
compris d'ailleurs des médecins libéraux
donc nous avons la France a la capacité
de faire cette consultation mais ils
veulent pas la faire moi je me souviens
en 2014 nous avons participé à une
consultation sur les personnes âgées au
Conseil économique et social ils ont
fait un rapport absolument remarquable à
l'unanimité des représentants du Conseil
comics social ce n'est pas écouté c'est
à dire qu'en fait quand les parlements
décident quelque chose ce n'est pas
écouté parce que vous avez des lobbies
importants qui ne veulent pas faire
changer les choses de tout de mots lobby
c'est les syndicats certains syndicats
médicaux
les grandes industries pharmaceutiques
qui sont derrière c'est beaucoup plus
vaste que ça l'un des plus gros
lobbistes au niveau du Parlement
européen c'est le Big Pharma
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut savoir que tout
ça tout ce dont on parle là ça fait
consommer du médicament parfois de
manière abusive parce que tout est très
bien et donc il y a des gens qui se
marquis sur ce point loi cadre grande
réforme il faut il nous faut
incontestablement une réforme systémique
il faut arrêter de bricoler il faut une
grande réforme cette grande réforme elle
ne peut passer que par une vraie
démocratie sanitaire ce qui n'existe pas
dans notre pays c'est-à-dire il faut que
l'on soit capable d'avoir à la
gouvernance du soin à la fois les
soignants et l'administration ce qui
existe déjà mais également les patients
mais les patients ça veut dire qu'il
faut les libérer de la tutelle de l'État
aujourd'hui ils sont tenus financés par
la tutelle de l'État il faut les libérer
il faut les rendre totalement libre pour
qu'il soit décideurs il faut que chaque
partie est un droit d'opposition c'est à
dire que le système ne puisse avancer
que si les trois parties sont d'accord
les patients les soignants
l'administration ça c'est fondamental et
puis il faut croire en l'Homme moi je
suis relativement optimiste ça va vous
surprendre mais je crois que le
balancier est allé tellement loin dans
la déshumanisation qu'il va revenir et
on va croire en l'Homme aujourd'hui ce
qui se passe c'est qu'on a à la fois des
hôpitaux qui s'effondent et dans la
crise née les mots Nestlé les monstres
c'est à dire que vous avez une
finalisation qui est en train de poser
la main sur le soin on le voit dans des
grands groupes de cliniques on le voit
dans une commercialisation du soin et ça
c'est extrêmement dangereux et si le
politique ne prend pas en compte ce
facteur-là qui n'est de la
déshumanisation et du fait qu'on a
écarté les soins de la décision et qu'on
a laissé le marché
Jacques Villiers nouvelle concertation
sur de nouveaux Ségur mais il y en a
déjà eu beaucoup et je vois pas très
bien sur ça apporterait de plus je vais
faire du remarques la première c'est que
toute l'Europe est en crise toute
l'Europe pas seulement nous et ils n'ont
pas trouvé ailleurs des solutions non
plus l'Espagne le Portugal la Grèce la
Grande-Bretagne donc où trouver les
solutions bon et deuxièmement il faut
bien avoir conscience que nous ne nous
considérons comme dirait Patrick en
urgence absolue mais nous ne sommes pas
les seuls nous ne sommes pas les seuls
et simplement regardons l'armée l'armée
400 milliards de budget en disant nous
ne sommes plus capables de soutenir un
conflit de haute intensité il faut
moderniser on est sortis du quoi qu'il
en coûte donc les 400 millions pour
l'armée oui bah voilà comment est-ce
qu'on peut comment est-ce qu'on peut
quitter la guerre est en Europe monsieur
robinet un mot sortons de la politique
des petits pas que ce soit sur le
sanitaire comme d'ailleurs sur la
question du grand âge on nous promet les
grands soirs moi je ne veux plus je
dirais de CNR et autres c'est-à-dire le
constat il est connu le diagnostic est
partagé partout donc maintenant il nous
faut des actes j'ai entendu prendre la
République qui d'ailleurs dans son
discours pour être totalement objectif
donne des ambitions donne des directions
c'est très bien
reprend je dirais peut-être les
inquiétudes des usagers des patients des
pays qui nous écoutent quand vous lui
parlez alors je ne
je n'ai pas un contact direct avec le
prendre la République mon contact est le
ministre de la santé ou le ministre des
Solidarités ou la ministre délégué on a
un contact quasi régulier oui il y a une
écoute mais vous savez comme on le dit
toujours il faut ensuite des preuves
donc nous attendons aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement agisse le diagnostic qu'il
est connu il y a des solutions mais vous
êtes à généraux de la santé mais si pour
faire des généraux pour perdre encore 6
mois pour se regarder dans le blanc des
yeux et refaire le diagnostic et le
constat vous savez le constat il a été
fait entre nous lors de lors de cette
émission donc on le connaît maintenant
aujourd'hui il y a des solutions des
propositions apportées par la FHF mais
comme par d'autres comme par les
syndicats de médecins libéraux par
d'autres syndicats par d'autres
fédérations moi ce que je souhaite c'est
que à la rigueur n'attendons pas des
injonctions de l'État nous savons
responsabiliser mettons-nous nous nous
les représentants du monde de la santé
autour de la table et sortant de la
salle quand au moment de la fumée
blanche est européenne mais la France
est un phare la France est un exemple au
niveau de la santé et cet exemple là
cette responsabilité de l'exemple nous
oblige ok merci vous le mot de la fin
nous oblige comme vous dites alors il me
reste à présenter un peu une
bibliographie bon en tout cas vous avez
les uns et les autres publier des livres
même s'ils ne sont pas d'une brûlante
actualité Arnaud Robinet avec Jacques
bichon vous avez écrit ce livre il y a
quelques années la mort de l'État
providence vivent les assurances
sociales est-ce qu'à votre avis il est
toujours d'actualité je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il soit encore véritablement
d'actualité au vu de la situation mais
vous savez pour le la prise en charge il
fait un son on aura besoin de tout le
monde et notamment dans le cadre de la
prise en charge de nos aînés et
notamment c'est-à-dire que l'évolution
de la société du vieillissement de la
population de la société doit s'hab doit
s'adapter de façon transversale et je
pense que nous aurons besoin de tout le
monde parce que c'est un devoir de
prendre soin de nos aînés et de leur
permettre d'avoir une fin de vie je
dirais digne merci Monsieur robinet
alors Patrick Peloux lui Urgence de
vivre
on cherche midi vous êtes toujours dans
l'urgence toujours merci ça fait plaisir
que vous montriez vous avez plus de
cheveux non j'avais plus de cheveux
pourquoi vous avez associé urgence et
vivre de voilà parce que je pense que
les deux sont intimement liés en fait
alors Jérôme Marty je crois que vous
avez publié le scandale des soignants
contaminés chez Flammarion ça reste un
grand problème ça vous avez voulu
dénoncer cette ça a été alors de tout ce
qu'on a dit là c'est à dire l'oubli des
soignants on a organisé la covid sans
tenir compte des soignants au départ
sans les protéger sans être en capacité
de les protéger parce que économiquement
on avait fait des coupes sur des
endroits où l'on pensait que waouh ça
servirait pas quoi et donc on a au juste
oublié d'armer les soignants et ça a été
catastrophique et ça a créé cette
contamination des soignants avec des
morts à la clé une médecine générale qui
a payé un très lourd tribu avec 75 morts
de soigner donc c'est un drame absolu
qu'on a vécu et on espère une seule
chose c'est qu'on le revivra plus et là
aussi s'il est patient avait été là dans
l'organisation du soin jamais ils
auraient laissé le fait de manquer des
masques alors Jacques billiez vous
reprenez la tradition des grands
médecins
qui ont une attraction particulière pour
la littérature vous avez publié beaucoup
d'ouvrages de même des romans policiers
je crois vous avez publié un ouvrage sur
la GPA
vous avez évolué depuis sur la GPA où
vous considérez que j'ai évolué
c'est-à-dire que je suis de plus en plus
convaincu que c'est un bon traitement de
stérilité utérine contrairement enfin
contrairement qui va dans le sens de
l'opinion publique d'ailleurs mais c'est
pas le lieu ni le moment de battre de
cela voilà merci voilà
merci
messieurs d'avoir participé activement à
cette émission et d'avoir défendu
ce qui est votre domaine à savoir la
santé merci à l'équipe de LCP qui permet
la réalisation de cette émission avant
de nous quitter je voudrais vous laisser
avec cette pensée en cette nouvelle
année on ne demande pas grand chose du
travail et de la santé Patrick Pelloux
c'est qui d'après vous
de Monsieur robinet
alors c'est pas de Monsieur robinet mais
c'est d'un auteur que nous soyons tous
Albert Camus
[Musique]